♪ I've been playing soccer
on a hot summer day. ♪
♪ I love a frozen fruit pop
right after I play. ♪
Who doesn't?
♪ But even though
I want one, ♪
♪ I just stand at the sink. ♪
♪ 'Cause I'm so hot and tired
that I can't even think. ♪
♪ In case I can't remember
how to cool myself down, ♪
♪ I wrote the steps on paper;
I can pass them around. ♪
♪ Read me the instructions
and I'll follow along, ♪
♪ and I'll have my refreshment
by the end of the song. ♪
♪ We get where you're going. ♪
♪ We'll get in a line ♪
♪ and read the instructions
one page at a time. ♪
♪ Open up the freezer door. ♪
♪ Get out the pop
that you're looking for. ♪
♪ Have a taste
and shout hooray! ♪
Hooray?
♪ Take off the wrapper
and throw it away. ♪
[KASSI GROANS]
♪ That wasn't as refreshing ♪
as I would have thought. ♪
♪ But we can solve a problem ♪
♪ with the steps
that we've got. ♪
♪ The secret is the sequence,
the order they're in. ♪
♪ So rearrange the sequence
and we'll sing it again. ♪
♪ We need a new sequence,
so mix up the line ♪
♪ and read the instructions
one page at a time. ♪
♪ Open up the freezer door. ♪
♪ Get out the pop
that you're looking for. ♪
♪ Take off the wrapper
and throw it away. ♪
♪ Have a taste
and shout hooray! ♪
♪ Hooray! ♪
Hooray!
♪ Helpsters! ♪
♪